[Music]
our favorite billionaire weirdo is times
person of the year doe
elon musk never heard of him
has been named due to the year by the
magazine you forgot was there
which prompted him to spend an extra
hundred dollars so he could own time as
well
in addition to being the world's richest
man the ceo of tesla and founder of
spacex elon is also a major advocate for
colonizing mars that's a planet cat
and getting weird haircuts after 50.
i believe that particular style is
called i'm super rich so you're going to
sleep with me anyway
that's why elon was chosen this year
time writes in their profile quote musk
has spent a lifetime defying the haters
what now it seems he's finally in
position to put them in their place for
2021 with a year of elon unbound
what because before this year he was
just a genius multi-billionaire that
dated beautiful actresses
looks like the top the magazine is late
again pretty bad for a magazine named
time
time also says elon is one of the few
people worthy of being described as
larger than life
i suppose they haven't met you know who
[Applause]
but is musk really the right choice for
2021's person of the year while brian
killme's therapist goes unrecognized
and what about the yak who grew cat's
hair extensions
talk about an unsung hero
let's make a quick round out of this
dagin uh who should be uh person of the
year should it rhyme with smeg smutfeld
no i think it should be the person who
still reads time
like single person yeah it's one person
yeah exactly what do you think it's a
pamphlet larry uh who should be the
times person of the year do you think
that i actually do think this is a good
choice i'd love to i love elon musk i
think elon musk is terrific yeah he's
really smart and here's another thing i
really love about him i'm surprised the
lefties who have given this award he is
the biggest electric car maker right
right number one so he has come out
totally opposed to all of biden's green
new deal subsidies for electric cars and
batteries he's against them and that's
very cool in fact he just came out
against biden's entire bill which the
rest of the country also hates so for a
ceo and a smart guy and they time put
him on the cover he's a conservative
he's a libertarian he's very cool yeah
for him i like the guy you know tyrus uh
is he a savior or a super villain
uh he's neither he's
he's a he's their
hope
he's the moderate democrats hope yeah i
don't know if he's he's because
the progressives hate him yeah first of
all he doesn't fill in enough box to be
a person of the year
having accomplishments by just pure
being good with money that's well that's
racist
so he's out of there you know and he's i
hate to be the one to bring this up but
apparently he's a white male and
straight yeah straight and straight
apparently he's a breeder yes
you get a couple of breeders in your
neighborhood all hell breaks oh my god
yep they're little things running around
what are those things anyway they're i
don't know they're bad but yeah
so he is disqualified
by every leftist magazine on the planet
and time is going maybe elon can do he
he could stand up to him he stand up to
biden he's still here you can't cancel
him yeah cause he'll just write you a
check yeah
i wish he'd write me a check you know
kat i should be man of the year for
rescuing late night from the humorless
left
huh
they agree
they agree
how'd that feel good yeah ten thousand
people in the audience
someone might agree with you yeah you
should yes okay i don't get this if
influential like to like he i'm not
influenced by him
no no okay then who would you want i
mean i think that ev you're lying
everyone's lying if you say anyone other
than your own self is your own selves
person influential of the year ah that's
interesting they'll put a mirror yeah me
for me they did that once didn't they do
that once for a time yeah they did and
then everyone's like puts in their
twitter bio like this is your most
virtual person they think they're really
funny but they're not because it's not
that easy to be funny
it's not it's not it's very very hard
and i think our show proves that again
and again
for example in this segment
all right up next peloton took pity
after a death on sex in the city